gang that middle-class famous tour is
coming your way and it's coming fast
we just added a bunch of new cities it's
a fantastic time stand-up comedy show
plus we play a little ayg with the crowd
it's a fantastic way to introduce the
new bozos and the new homies to the show
so get the squad and come out and see us
yeah guys in august we're going to be in
red bank new jersey that show is about
to sell out then we're going to seattle
portland september we're going to be in
kansas city springfield and st louis
then in october or in nashville indy
we're in philadelphia yikes coming home
then december we're in providence rhode
island and boston get those tickets
those shows will sell out see you there
welcome to another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals or absolute trash
now here are your hosts kevin ryan and h
foley
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's favorite new podcast this
is are you garbage oh yeah little show
we sit down with your favorite comedians
and we find out they're good to be
classy yeah after just a big old piece
of trash
i'm your host holy coming at you on a
beautiful day down here at aunt toddy's
basement she's all excited she says our
problems are over tell me more she
landed a mummer baby
nice and if you don't know what a mummer
is do yourself a favor give it a goog
did she knock him off the float
knocked him off the back of the u-haul
knocked him off the bunk beds he was
sleeping on i think my co-host is coming
at you from right next to me he is the
ceo of ru garbage he is international
businessman he is the prince of park
avenue but always the king of the
boardwalk baby give it up for my best
pal kj kevin james ryan shout out to
wildwood new jersey hey guys thanks for
tuning in uh
check out make sure you rate view
subscribe on itunes full video available
on youtube as you know those numbers are
true
cooking then the greatest goddamn
website of all [ __ ] [ __ ]
time
www.patreon.com so i'll show you garbage
check it the [ __ ] out a lot of good
stuff going on over there it's a good
good time and having a nice quick shout
out to our producer extraordinaire the
magic man he makes us all look good give
it up for mr toby mcmullen what's up
dudes t-bone hey this is a [ __ ] la
vibe in new york today
i feel like we're in the back of a
cadillac
about to go get my surfboard this girl
brings the vibes you guys cannot surf i
would love to see your [ __ ] ass on a
[ __ ] surfboard i can shred there's no
at the at wildwood anywhere oh yeah in
the brown water
shout out to the seaweed i do love i do
love surfing jeans i love it i love it
ladies and gentlemen you know where you
love her she's one of the co-hosts of
the amazing podcast trash tuesdays give
it up for andy letterman hey buddy there
she is
no one really has ever rolled with the
crew maybe a friend or uh
i want an entourage yeah no hair no hair
makeup people and [ __ ] uh somebody
holding an umbrella for you i wanna
that's what i want that's what you wanna
do i watched the jlo documentary and i
was like i gotta get a
cup with a bunch of crystals i just
watched that too that was pretty good i
was like that looked like a 50 000 mugs
all i thought it was like i gotta get
that mug
that was the whole that was my takeaway
it seems like a tortured life though
it's a lot you're just constantly yeah
you don't want that you're freewheeling
you're rolling around with your luggage
your free spirit here and there the
luggage is nice by the way she does have
a nice setup with you guys
the lug is just trash
it's got your init there's not you're
they're not no it says because whose
initials are they they're not yours
after
looks like a j but that's because it's a
joke with my dad okay years ago sounds
like
christmas
years ago uh around christmas i was
sending my i was living at home and
hanging out with my dad a lot i was like
23. we went to the post office i was
going to send my friend a
i don't know i was sending i think i was
sending butt wipes to everyone for
christmas that was like my funny joke
okay how old were you 23 23 23 oh my god
that guy's out to lunch again
do you want to borrow one of my coffees
um okay so we're at the post office i'm
sending this package my dad's done
sending his stuff he's waiting at the
door i'm taking away i'm writing my
friend a little letter and my dad goes
like he's like come on honey like bored
like joke in a fight you know and i was
like shut the [ __ ] up dad i'm
i'll take my time or we're having like a
joke little thing between me and my dad
i'm sure this is actually a screaming no
no no no it wasn't it was all fun and
this old lady i promise i had no lies
here
um i this old lady right as she's about
to go like pivots and she goes you know
what young lady you're a real itch
and my dad started to see the [ __ ]
she'll want to say the bee i don't know
what it i mean it sounds like an old
lady insult
i assume maybe she wanted to say [ __ ]
but yeah but that's where my dad when my
dad went actually she's more of an aunt
as i put it as hunt oh my dad's got good
ones one time i gained weight we were on
a vacation it's a cold open right there
yeah i gained like 15 pounds we were on
vacation i was diving into a diet i know
i had a feeling i was always diving you
know 50.
i said one five not five zero but um i
was diving off the dock and midair my
dad goes look it's annie weight gaines
instead of greg louganis that's pretty
good he's good my dad's quick
i like this guy where's he at right
on vacation he's just 80 just chilling
jesus that's 80. he's 80. you're all
with an old dad my dad's old
wow how old was he when he when he had
you but this is where it gets dark okay
oh god he's 41. this is a record roll
we made it three minutes he was 41. okay
that's actually not that's how old i'm
gonna be i'm gonna be an elderly mother
yeah i'm gonna be an old dad too i'm 46.
i remember my my dad had my younger
brother and we went to the i know right
that's you're gonna be like a really old
dad if i yeah i might even have kids
i might be a dead dad to be honest with
you little though you look young thank
you thank you you got baby face
thank you he's got the skin i don't know
i like it
i don't know you've been talking you
haven't been called little in a while
just take the [ __ ] compliment his
dick gets called little all the time i
have to say parts of him are called
little nobody looking me in the eye i
said it let's just say that
[Laughter]
lies i'm killing you
all right okay what were you gonna say
nothing so you had an old dad did that
was there any time did you ever get made
fun of for having an old dad like look
at annie's old [ __ ] nobody made it in
front of me but i was just under stress
and and worry all the time i was just
always if my dad didn't answer like if i
was like dad his office was upstairs if
he didn't answer i was like dad's dead
emergency style you know i'm like oh my
god i look at it in the way that i'll be
older i'll leave the kid earlier you
know i'll die earlier but i'll be able
to set him up better
for the rest of his life and also too
that's a very holy way to speak hold on
and also too i was thinking about it
it'll benefit the kids if it happens to
him when he's like 20 or 21 luckily then
when he has a family he doesn't got to
worry about coming to see coming to see
me or
whether i'm in a nursing home or getting
old or whatever
he doesn't want me there eating all the
turkey he wants a bite too
we are in the depths of foleyville look
at what i'm saving them on pumpkin pie
really
[Laughter]
you guys i have to compliment you your
podcast is the best thank you oh thank
you it's so good i mean i don't watch it
but i did watch it
i did watch my episode it looks great
not the whole one uh god forbid i watch
the whole [ __ ] one i'll come watch
the clip all right but i love the clips
it looks beautiful you guys just the way
you uh you open the show is so good
thank you
it's like class acts but trash
a little bit i know it's so hard to stay
trashy when you're [ __ ] rich
it's crazy
[Laughter]
ah i'm talking about new money all you
gotta do is like the way to say trash is
brag about it i guess so like that's all
they do well have you done anything
stupid with the money you know since
we've seen you last year you think crazy
[ __ ] that's fake
it [ __ ]
[Laughter]
uh well this is i'm sorry please i wanna
what's something like that cost what's a
louis vuitton purse like that cost i
don't even know dude how what do you
mean don't even know i just give them
the card yeah
you don't look like price tags i look i
don't look at price tags really you're
there there that's crazy listen i'm not
gonna go like look at the biggest purse
you know i'm not gonna go like i'm not
gonna go look at the luggage and go
don't just charge it that's over a
thousand dollars though right oh yeah
this is probably really yeah we could
look it up it's probably two no it's
okay don't look it up i take your word
for it i like that it's pretty good not
looking at a jihad that's pretty good
yeah what kind of equipment are you
rolling with i have a tesla really i
meant credit card what do you got amex
capital one where are you at don't pull
it you don't got to pull it out wait
hold on
it twists whoa she has a blow pop in her
person everybody knows i think it was a
tampon
no it's just my business name okay it's
my company name my the car this number
when you're rich i have one i got i got
one but it's gold yeah ours is gold hers
is platinum now i think yours might be
better yeah yours is better is that a
platinum or sure sure yeah yeah that's
pretty good
i just got denied for a platinum a
personal platinum by the way what's
going on with um
with the sky lounge we don't get in oh i
was going to ask sky lounge we don't get
in because we don't have the platinum uh
we're delta
i'm gonna this is the first year we're
traveling so we've been kicked out of
about four delta yeah we try at every
airport the key is to try to grab a
handful of pretzels i'm american i'm
american i'm not a nicer place isn't it
i'm an amer i'm an american girl now
that's a little trash i may switch i may
switch well dragging people off flights
and shits
that's that they're the ones always in
nuts i don't know i'm united's band i'm
in first class i don't know what's
happening back there but um
i couldn't i couldn't bother myself with
the back of the plane but um their
their lounge is like hard-boiled eggs
like you go in and you're like okay i'll
have a couple hard-boiled eggs i'll have
a free coffee yeah they're not the
lounges aren't that
great some of them are really good but
most of them are just like i hate the
hard boiled egg too is like the power
breakfast for for for smart wealthy on
the road i'm in on the run you're like i
got to just pop an egg
i'm making business deals so weird i'm
trading i'm trading smell like an
it's like it's like you know what it is
it's when garbage people are trying to
be healthy
yeah that's what yeah yeah for sure well
here this is this came in it's not a
ques it's more of a philosophical
question a little bit uh this is from
chris
uh
why is it so much more fun to be garbage
not broke just
you know us essentially have a little
bit of you know
you're not poor
than it is to be classy like why is it
are you the kind of person that likes
going to a really nice place or you
still like going to like a dive bar in a
food truck or do you like do you are you
really leaning into it it's just hard i
leaned into the nicer
restaurants last night i leaned into the
show and had halal i was like what's
more garbage treat me
street meat at like four in the morning
i was so wasted
i was high
credit eating it out of a louis vuitton
bag
[Laughter]
uh i had it delivered though okay that's
car me there's car meet uh carby
i thought that was like a new corvanna
website
uber car meet um because i do like i go
to fancy restaurants i've been to fancy
restaurants i'll go but i just do love
walking into a dive bar or you know a
hole in the wall or a food truck that's
more me i can acclimate to a nicer place
but no no there's no acclimation there's
no acclimation you go straight trash
into the fancy restaurant you make them
come to you and change the way i don't
have the confidence for that
yes for a straw with like their coffee
do you have any i'm sorry do you have
any plastic straws
any solo cups back there give me two
sweet and lou's i always bring in i
always bring in an outside drink i dare
them i don't oh that's crazy i dare them
i dare them to tell me to throw my drink
out yeah they're gonna they should
what kind of like a water walk in like
you're somebody yeah i don't have that i
can't walk into mr chow's with a [ __ ]
gatorade now i gotta tell you guys
i did something for the first time that
felt really good i went to a restaurant
in l.a all right and we weren't dressed
you know we were in our sweats which is
a kind of a power move in l.a well
that's the thing i'm really very rich
the shittier you're dressed the richer
you look unless you like smell bad you
can't smell better sure
i'm out you have to be like between the
homeless and between the richest person
that's the person in the penthouse and
the person yeah in the box yeah yeah
that's what i've noticed that you can
get away with looking trashy or like the
more you dress up it's like you don't
belong there yeah yeah but i mean this
it is trashy to buy like person i mean
it is like you know the essence of what
i'm doing i wouldn't say i mean that's
trash i would say that's pretty that's
pretty classy no it's
time it's classy to own it's trashy to
pull out on camera 100 100 that's the
philly dirt bag
look at this look at this look that's
but i will old money don't do that i
would very understand i would assume
you're not spending above your means i
think you could really afford that right
everything i make as much money as i
want
we all can just make you know that right
we could just make as much money sure
hey guys garyvee take it easy
they call me gary vagina
call her hairy vagina what's up
let me ask you this about the about the
dinner that's pretty good everybody
guys i will be now doing characters
okay i was a prop comic first and now no
the truth is i actually kind of have
always been a prop comic i always will
bring something stupid on stage or
whatever so now my props have just
gotten a little more expensive there you
go okay so like what's uh what's a bit
you would do with the sunglasses what do
you mean oh i punctuate my jokes with
different sunglasses i have different
glasses
you know like if i want to seem smart i
put on the readers you know they don't
make you seem smart i'm sorry they make
you seem super creepy
well these are transition lenses which
is kind of garbage i got it yeah no they
are that is yeah it looks like you're
shaving points on the cleveland game
yeah but it looks like ace rolstein in
that
i can still
[Laughter]
when you go to dinner
where's the line of where annie picks up
the check and where's the line of where
hey we're splitting it
i pick it up you pick it up yeah most
people want to pick it up i pick it up
how many people are we talking like when
you say hey let's go out to dinner like
not more than probably i've never picked
up like a table of like more than
two like a double date okay oh really
i've never but i don't go hang out that
much like i don't like i i hang out my
boyfriend and i got to eat a lot but but
you got but but you got on a double date
and you and annie will pick up to check
mm-hmm that's pretty [ __ ] classy
right that's a passion unless people
want to do that 100
move no 100 i love that i've been so
broke
my whole life like not my whole life i
had a shot they gave me a shot as a
child and it just didn't work out i was
hitchhiking into the city i was like
that's supposed to be with you i gotta
get to a rave down on [ __ ] delaware
oh i gotta go to a phone party at
shampoo yeah i gotta get the gotham
nightclub
shout out to the phone parties and
shampoo i think we're on wednesday night
god that was [ __ ] fun i never went
but i heard about him on the radio
[ __ ] disgusting though
i remember i remember through hearing
what i remember hearing that and
thinking as like a sixth grader like
whoever is at those things is a pure
dirtbag the anxiety well i was in
seventh grade
yeah yeah
seventh and eighth grade is around when
when we went i only went a few times
with my friends it was anxiety written
well it's just disgusting i can't really
see you fitting into that oh not at all
a little fat kid with a [ __ ] raiders
hat on it
hanging out by the kitchen to pick off
the server the anxiety was brutal
leading up to it oh my god were you the
cutest kid i was a chubby i was a little
chubster and i didn't have no dance
moves oh yeah not having dance moves as
a chubby kid is a real oh i was
petrified of everything and like i would
build up and ask one girl to dance it
would take me that we were there for two
hours the preparation would take until
like the last song and then i would
dance like that it was always stairway
to heaven oh yeah
never anything fast but also okay wait
so
i think that's that was good and just
someone comes on you make it i gotta go
to bed where's the bathroom at well you
know how there was like i think i pulled
a hammy in there
i'm a bad dancer i'm like you know i get
like insecure like people are watching
me and stuff and everyone's like
nobody's watching you as a fat kid
everyone's watching everyone
everyone's like relying on you they're
like pull it together fat guys you
better
entertain us all i'm doing the mashed
potatoes yeah you either yeah you either
have to go and like you have to own it
and be like i'm doing the truffle
shuffle yeah or just not dance yeah it's
a bit you gotta go yeah you gotta go you
can't just sit there in two step you
know yeah people are gonna be gonna be
taking a cannonball
exactly you got a side show it really
circus it up
it's sad you knew all the dances but
couldn't do them
he was just watching them all the time
i'm doing the macarena from my seat just
doing a hand that's the one i could do
that one that's a real white guy thing
just dance them all sitting down you
know because you don't have to line up
the feet in the arms the upper body's
all right i'll do this all shout out to
the uncles and the dads that no matter
what the [ __ ] was happening at the
wedding on a dance floor they [ __ ]
sat right there drinking a cup of decaf
watching the action oh a deacon shout
out to uncle den oh man
nothing changing just sitting there the
exact same
five the whole time just enjoying it
doesn't matter if the limbo is going on
good i'm good i want to sit i want to
sit how about the dad that goes to
disney and just sits or goes to six
flags and just chills you just go meet
him yeah i'll be here i'll be here
no help
no never give you a big stack of [ __ ]
tickets and tell you are you guys six
flags people are you really we were down
the shore we grew up going down the
shore at a while away six flags
six flags every i think it was about
every summer about 20 of us what about
dorney park did you go to jordan park
dorney park
did you guys go to um sesame street i
lived i grew up like 10 minutes from
sesame place did you go on the ropes and
it hurt your feet do you remember i
remember like crying and screaming like
trapped in these [ __ ] ropes because
it just they would like
pelt your feet like you're walking like
it was the most painful [ __ ] i literally
remember i had to be right 23.
miss get off of the ropes
and guys my feet have never looked the
same that's why i picked lately
and the same thing as the shampoo
nightclub they used to have not disney
uh sesame after dark which is when like
you know [ __ ] molested you
when they [ __ ] your [ __ ] child
[ __ ] big bird fingers your [ __ ]
uh no like if you left for like the
trash
would go after dark and it would be like
you know you would you and everybody's
like oh we're going and i'm like dude i
am not going to land any broads if i'm
if i'm if i'm going down shotgun falls
without his shirt off i'm screwed
he got grover as a wingman i'm the size
of a linebacker in [ __ ] sixth grade
it ain't happening these two i'm only
going to jam all of us up kev let's talk
about helix i love that helix our good
friends over there the helix gang you
don't want to spend your time in a
mattress door walking around talking to
some guy with coffee breath when you can
go on helix and you can [ __ ] take the
quiz and they can match you with the
perfect mattress
i had sex in the helix recently by
myself
uh everybody is unique and helix knows
that so they have several different
mattress models to choose from
they have soft medium firm mattresses
mattresses great for cooling you down if
you sleep high mattresses for spinal
alignment prevent morning aches and
pains and even helix plus for the big
mean yeah uh guys the quiz takes two
minutes me my lady took it took to took
the quiz two minutes we got the uh
twilight mattress and i love it we loved
it so much we upgraded to a king size
look at that got a pocket for that there
you go yolks is awesome but you don't
need to take our word for it it was
selected number one best overall
mattress pick of 2020 by gq and wired
magazine just go to helixsleep.com
garbage
take your two minutes leave quiz and
they'll match you with a customized
mattress that'll give you the best sleep
of your life i'm telling you but don't
take my word for it they have a 10 year
warranty and you get to try it out for a
hundred nights risk free they'll even
pick it up if you don't love it but you
will helix even has financing options
from flexible payment plans so a great
night's sleep is never far away helix is
offering up to 200 off all mattress
orders and two free pillows for our
listeners at helix sleep.com slash
garbage one more time he'll sleep.com
garbage do it now the words from our
sponsor better help yes gang
you gotta take care of yourself you
gotta you take care you clean your room
you make your bed you go to the gym you
try to eat right you do all this stuff
but what are you doing for your mental
health yeah better help can help got to
get your brain good get your brain going
good get it working again get your
english going good yeah there you go
guys uh mental health is a big part of
everybody's life whether you want to
admit it or not everybody can benefit
from we struggle with it we struggle
with it and talk therapy has helped me
immensely in my life with my personal
relationships and my journeys in comedy
with everything i used to talk it was
fantastic i can't recommend it enough
better help is online therapy that
offers video phone and even live chat
only therapy sessions so you don't have
to see anyone on camera if you don't
want to it's much more affordable than
in-person therapy
and you can be matched with a therapist
in under 48 hours which if you've ever
tried to do it is huge huge it can take
weeks or months to get a hold of
somebody they call you back you leave a
message they're in their office hours
they call you back it gets all jammed up
meanwhile you're losing it you're losing
it and the town you live in might not
have the specialist or whatever that you
need
you got a wide variety over there sure
do
okay our listeners get 10 off their
first month to betterhealth.com garbage
that's better help h-e-l-p dot-com slash
garbage do it do it please we had one
called beach street and it was in
nightclub for there's a lot of bar and
bought mitzvahs and stuff there but
there was like a nightclub just for like
three teens no i grew up with a lot of
jewish of course we all did um hard to
escape you know
uh ended up marrying one through a hell
of a birthday party i'll tell you that
they know how to dance shout out to them
god damn oh god shout out to rubenstein
honestly when they pick that chair up
i'm like i want to be more jewish no but
you know what i forgot
at my wedding we smashed the glass are
you married yeah
you just looked at my hand too i hate
when people don't wear rings i don't
wear a ring it's disgusting i gotta
still land chicks you know what i mean
uh
two like two a little over two years ago
and then you hit it yeah then he hit it
back yeah i said many times
it was her she gave us the money to open
the studio so it's all her oh she is
joking
good girl and the juice is still running
she wants that money back i'm sure
there's an interesting i keep making
interest on the loan i'm like with the
u.s taxing you know the whole thing 80
interest and that's family and friends
pricing so guys i
okay so i was always i always knew that
my dad's father was jewish
and our last name's jewish
but we were brought up quaker and and
you know we were surrounded by jews we
tried to kind of play in and we had a
party i think i told you guys this last
time we had a part when we were 13
and like our big we had my parents gave
us like a bigger party more than usual
and everyone was like all the jewish
kids were like you're trying to copy oh
copy or borrow bot mitzvah i'm like i'm
not reading a [ __ ] torah [ __ ] you're
the one up there [ __ ] embarrassing
those are [ __ ] money makers though
man i know people did make money i would
love to have bat mitzvah bar mitzvah
those kids cleaned up 20 30 grand not to
mention they dropped like 100 i know i
got some balloons i got to huff that's
what i like [ __ ] i never got [ __ ]
any time i made any significant
i don't think they gave him to eat a hug
but christmas was way well i certainly
found a way
christmas was what did he want the
nitrous tank oh my god i would have been
so happy man thank you nitrous came on
the scene that i don't like got big with
my crew when we were in like our early
20s to the point where it was like a
pregame i'm putting it on my rider
i wanted [ __ ] nitrous a three foot
tank my body would change okay i gotta
find ways to get [ __ ] up i'm like a
nature's tank doesn't count
i got it for the best that's real
if you get a root canal no
and he just loves dentistry huh
i actually do like going to the dentist
really yeah they're like waiting on you
it's like so awesome i feel like a queen
they're like flossing my teeth for me
that's the that's the real dirt bag in
you you want to feel fancy yeah you like
my teeth i had to find my fancy places
where i could sure no i get it i get it
it would be dangerous as like a dictator
you would be dangerous
[Laughter]
i don't know maybe so give me a try guys
vote vote letterman a room full of shoes
and be heading fridays it's all like
dirty jordans
i will tell you i've never this is
actually i feel like lester park i think
it's more dirtbag to keep your jordans
clean
to try really hard there's something
because it's like you're so precious
that is like i could never get another
pair i you let you let them you look
you'll wear it i'm like i'll buy them
i'll buy them again yeah it used to be
when i was a kid back when i was banging
back when i was banging it was cooler to
have the sneakers dirty than have them
clean
you know what i mean yeah it was like it
was like way cool i'm telling you i
crease mine up right away yeah i go you
mean nothing to me i crunch them right
in front get on instagram
right in front of the kid at the store
will you wear anything out if you buy a
pair of shoes like i'm going to wear
these out i want to wear things out
always i would like to keep tags on i
think it's funny have you gone shopping
since you've been in the city no since
you've been here so yeah i don't have
time okay but i i do feel like um i like
to keep the tags on but that's like an
old dirt baggy thing because i used to
return the clothes
but i i don't want to give up my my true
roots
so i keep the tag i'm going to keep them
on i keep feel like i'm test driving but
i never i don't return they never return
it just keep them you're not working i
would pit them out and then return them
and be like i don't know what happened
somebody must have worn this someone put
like lemonade like poisonous like
smelling somebody must have wore this to
shampoo on a tuesday night did someone
take this to shampoo and wear it on the
bottom
someone take this shirt and wear it on
their
uh speaking of birthdays this is from
silky sull as a kid have you ever
attended a mcdonald's or burger king
play place birthday party do you ever go
to a birthday party at a fast food or
have your yes i mean i wasn't invited
but i certainly have been to one
i pop right in i invite myself into
parties really but yeah i've jumped in
yeah you're a very confident guy i could
see you doing that i think it was
honestly asperger's i don't like
sunglasses annie by the way
i don't like diva annie
it gets why creepo annie's back
there's like
semen on them
sorry are they all fancy are they both
fancy glasses yes these were of course
they were expensive
louis vuitton well now that i have money
louis vuitton glasses what are those i
don't know what the brand's called but
it was i let's just say i walked in a
pair of shady race this is what i do i
go when they're busy and they're like
helping other people i go hey just heads
up i'm looking to buy the most expensive
glasses you have here and then you're a
dirt bag do that you are a dirty bang
how are you tipping are you tipping good
oh i'm tipping the fattest you can be
tipped really okay holy level because
you got to be
no no no
i look at it like this like i do look at
like i may end up bankrupt but um i'm
pretty sure we're going that route but i
feel like if you give it out if you give
it out it comes back
so i just spent this spiritual so you're
telling me you walk into a louis vuitton
you're going to get sunglasses there i
the person's taking care of someone i
don't just go hey just so you know no
louis vuitton knows you're gonna spend
money they all they come to you
i've never waited they don't make you
wait
like they might be like you can't come
in the store yet but they don't let you
in that store until someone's with you
will you wait out front no you they like
get your number and then you go oh well
they get your number they'll never don't
do that
i walk right into target well they
pretend like they have like a personal
relationship like they'll text you and
be like how you liking your purse
okay it's like jeanette from louie like
how's it going yeah cause they want to
keep you coming and i'm going back i'm
going back to new york
yeah really but so
yeah but i'm new to all this and i i'm
so used to like looking at things i like
and then not getting them you know so
what i make a rule i don't go into the
store unless i'm going to leave with
something really because i don't want to
play that game anymore it is it is last
it's like it's like yeah that's very i
look at it
no no it's not status it's like um for
my like
the way i think about money i want to i
want to treat myself like
i can afford things
i don't want to go into places i can't
afford things which arguably i think
you can
yeah you can't afford them i mean i
think you guys could afford it we treat
ourselves nice we just flew uh first
class from here to buffalo so you know
we're doing all right
that was a 14-minute flight not the
break here's the tell are you putting
anything away do you got like some
investments going you have a retirement
sure i have a business manager you can
sell that purse anytime she wants i got
a purse collection
there you go
are you paying the taxes too taxes are
paid
set aside there you go
but i do want to i do want to invest in
stuff and
do all that i want to buy a house and do
that kind of stuff we're thinking about
investing in some sort of sports team
buying some amateurs you want to come in
with us you want to get in on that
somebody recommend that the pickleball
league is big pickleball league's big
it's at its infancy we could do like the
ayg pickleball team they have um
turtle racing in venice
we can sponsor a turtle okay well he
could get him
it was packed on a thursday i know i've
seen that i lift up thursday night and
they got to try they put them all in the
center and they lift it up and they got
to get out of this i've never been i
just drove by yeah either how long does
that take four hours i test the driving
the beers are cold who cares we'll get
that turtle juiced up get a little
[ __ ] d ball in him
start making some [ __ ] money coming
all yoked up
shotgun and meth in his face it is true
it's like as garbage people moving
forward
as investors we do have to invest in
garbage things oh yeah but you can't
invest you can't invest out of your like
race car team softball teams laundry
mats highlight some vending machines i
have a confession you want to come in on
some vending machines with us yes i
would do some vending machines
i think they're only a couple hundred
cooking for a couple hundred bucks only
funyuns there's nothing else in there
[Laughter]
nobody needs anything bunions and winter
fresh gum that's it oh yeah they never
the twine shall not meet they must be
together
i
have never been to a
nascar event neither of us i've never
been to a i've been to a race car rally
and like uh actual rally but what's a
race car rally like when the the dirt
but they're like dirt cars what do you
call that oh like the dirt tracks yeah
i've seen like the races in the mud yeah
yeah that's actually so funny i've only
been to amateur level
races and it's
a [ __ ] good time there have been any
illegal street races no well i think
this one might have been illegal not the
it wasn't a race it wasn't sanctioned
all right i don't think jeff gordon was
there yeah i don't think anyone was like
this is okay
it was just it wasn't he okay from
nascar for this it was up in um
it was in like williamsport
i could see you adventure it was illegal
i could see you high school like going
down to the races that was big you go
down by the airport everybody was drag
racing
and did you ever like date a guy who had
like a 96 mustang or something that had
like some gnaws in it and stuff like
that some flowmaster stickers on it my
boyfriend had a um he had a a plymouth
neon
but it had
a real gold guy he had rims and he would
people he cocked the car back
they rode like that huh
and his pants were falling off and then
he was in prison
there you go okay for what
um heroin
okay i didn't think that i think it was
a white collar crime
riga caught cooking the books at enron
[Laughter]
insurance fraud
well heroin i know it's like so
disappointing
could have been cooler um
all right this one's from josh g uh have
you ever hosted a garage sale
your family ever do garage sales
it's worse
my mom it always is with you manny
my mom
like her big investment when she's like
you know what i think i want to run a
business
she bought an ebay drop-off store
so our housing branding garage sale our
house was and she stopped doing it a
long time ago and there's just still
things in the house there's a lot of
like dusty dolls
i was just thinking about those the
other day they never took off and they
should have dusty dolls
that's a great band i like that they're
lazy they don't want to do it themselves
that's what i'm saying they make sense
of hey go drop this off give me the nine
or the cos the you know co-sign for it
they did good i think they just got
bored you know it was like
my mom and my brother our drop off ebay
store is next level derpy she was taking
the photos and [ __ ] yeah she was taking
the photos she was shipping it out she
liked doing it she liked the history of
the items like paul she's like figuring
out yeah exactly the best i can do is a
dollar fifty so there were other
people's things that would come and they
would say like she's the middle man
you're selling this for me so you would
take it to her if you had like a doll or
whatever you would take it to her
and you wanted to sell an ebay but
you're like i don't have an ebay account
i don't want my mom
if she sells it for 100 bucks she takes
30 yeah she takes
30 bucks she gives you 70. hmm that's
how horror movies start i don't like
that yeah i start following you oh get
the [ __ ] thank you did you have creepy
dolls when you were a kid i like my
grandmother got me like some dolls some
porcelain dolls and stuff but i my mom
was so so butch and so rejecting of
dolls that i never
i always had to pretend i didn't like
him did you have barbie and [ __ ] when
you were a kid yeah but my mom would be
like i don't get it and i'd be like nah
i'd make him like [ __ ] [ __ ] did your
mom do
my mom was she worked at wxba at the
radio station for a little bit she wrote
the newsletter
okay my mom uh she did traffic in the
weather she kind of just said
she worked at gray panthers which was an
organization for
out the elderly to fight against ageism
okay the gray pain isn't that like a
little appropriation sounds like a sweet
gang though
watch out here come together roll up on
their jazzies
gonna [ __ ] with you i heard you didn't
hire cheryl
they threatened you at needlepoint yeah
um
she worked at places where she was
almost volunteering like she didn't need
to you know like my dad was the best
she would just like hang out
okay
but
yikes um are we lulling we're not left
no no no not at all i'm processing
processing i'm just like should i have
taken the adderall no no i don't know i
don't need adderall though listen for
the record i think you want to take the
adderall i get it i think you're looking
for a reason i don't really want to take
it i don't boof it right now i swear to
god
i would snort it if i was going to do
anything is boofing up your ass yeah
yeah
that's good throw in your mouth
i guess this is brought to you by is now
is that not invisalign it's name it's
generic i'm jay no is that my tmj oh you
told me about this well we saw you last
week yeah
oh tightman she grinds your teeth at
night believe it or not well what's so
funny
you guys think i'm craziest craziest
thing you've ever done
not at all
crazy like a fox that's like great
expectations
i'm only hearing the fox part
did you have braces as a kid your teeth
are good yeah you got good teeth good
teeth good skin
oh my god
a louis vuitton mouth guard case is
brilliant there's a line there you go i
think i smell a new merch idea
i want to make yoni eggs what's that
it's like something gwyneth paltrow
talked about where it's like they're
like crystal eggs that girls are
supposed to or they're like jade or
something and they put them up their
[ __ ] what
i don't know if people really do them
but is that funny if it's like my face
on it
jeez start with some quail eggs or
something like that kippy
box awesome box of awesome businesses
shout out to the post the best post in
the business yeah you're never gonna
find a better post never gonna find a
cooler box awesome than bespoke post and
guess what it's summertime you wanna do
your grilling you wanna smell nice you
to look cool you want to have cool stuff
around the outside bar all right to make
to make yourself look cool in front of
the squad
get yourself a box awesome i'm telling
you right now yeah it's one of those
things that's cool guy [ __ ] you never
really thought of and then you see
somebody with you like damn how do you
where do you get that cool thing you got
a whole bottle opener
you got that long spoon you're doing
that yeah swizzler stick i call that
yeah get my hands on one of them i stole
one from my fridays i'm not allowed back
people who get box of awesome also
enjoy brandy cherries okay classy it's
one of those things too it's all that
cool guy [ __ ] where you're or gal [ __ ]
where you're like uh hey where'd you get
that yo this thing is thing is a little
hinky you got a name this carabiner
bottle opener pocket knife slash radar
detector i got it from the box awesome
yes i used the i used the knife they
gave me today not an actual product how
to cut dog poop out of my dog's hair uh
real cool guys [ __ ] brook lipstick
glamour gotta get started take the quiz
epoxy my new balance okay take the quiz
at box of awesome.com your answers will
help them pick the right box of awesome
for you they release new boxes every
month across a ton of different
categories each box is valued at around
70 but you only pay a fraction of that
price
plus a box of awesome you're supporting
small business 90 of everything that
comes from box of awesome is from small
upcoming brands yeah it's free to sign
up you can skip a month at any time or
cancel here we go baby the turkey get 20
off your first monthly box when you sign
up at box of awesome.com enter the code
garbage at checkout that's box of
awesome dot com code garbage for twenty
percent off your first box box office
dot com go garbage i'm back to the show
back to the show this one's from victor
ten dollar shareholder which i like we
should still start calling the patreon
shareholders love that made it a little
more official now we're now we're doing
well maybe organize the board of
directors
that's pretty good uh how do you hold a
fork and a knife
do you hold it do you have proper table
banners no i like i don't know which
fork or which spoon or anything yeah but
i'm saying if you it's really once you
give me once there's two and i'm like
why are there two here yeah depends who
she's stabbing
but i'll i'll i'll use a savory fork on
a sweet thing yeah that's what i'm
saying like a savory fork i've never
even heard of that no just you know like
you're eating something savory and then
the dessert comes like i'm not you don't
need it
okay okay i don't have time for that
okay very close yeah as well i don't
care about that what do you hold i watch
top chef i watch reality defense oh
there you go top chef's all right do you
go upside down do you do the european
style oh when i want to feel classy yeah
like you hold the fork
and then you use the knife to put your
you know what i want to bring back
actually hold on
the spork
chopsticks what do you got
oh you're all wrapped up it's worth it
here to go under here
okay all right
i'm bringing it back i'm with you a
hundred percent i'm bringing it back i'm
doing it
every podcast i do i'm gonna be like
this yeah that's cool that could be
that's your thing as a girl as a girl
i'm more like michelle pfeiffer but i'm
like telling a kid how it is yeah that's
like i care about you crazy minds
dangerous minds dangerous minds wow you
got crazy on the mind
[Laughter]
[Music]
i don't hurt the married boys um you got
a wife you can stay like i got abroad it
actually hurts so bad it was like
stretching
yeah i feel like i think guys are gonna
have like a [ __ ] bruise they don't
make chairs conducive for that you gotta
do that with like a small you gotta do
that with like a high school chair well
the chair that it has to the chairs that
go in like i don't mind if it's like
billowing out here but it's like my legs
were spread
all right a computer chair would be good
i was like this is like i'm doing a
[ __ ] split all of a sudden
shout out to the fawns
now okay
as a kid what were some sort of like
trash activities you did like did you
everything did your parents sign you up
for trashy things no i was kind of like
i never do a day camp
oh yeah i don't is that trashy though i
think so we did the park i don't think
it's classy what's the park thing
there's just a park behind our house and
my mom is like i it must have cost 15 a
summer
and they just send you up but we would
just leave whenever we wanted so it was
just like was there instructors there or
whatever there was counselors but they
had to have been like
15. yeah yeah yeah that's yeah that's
not a date camp and then there's like
another camp and sometimes we would go
to each other's camps i'm like i don't
think we're supposed to be leaving the
camp why are we all leaving the camp all
the time my mom signed me up for a bible
camp one time
or she like kind of it like she's irish
cats
fat bastard of the house for a couple
hours yeah and i remember going and i
remember i was like what the [ __ ] is
this dude i was i had no i was floating
around group to group and she picked me
up i'm like never again okay are you
leaving me at that [ __ ] place no
you're in a [ __ ] penalty box right
now were you guys like [ __ ] make me a
cheese sandwich were you guys fat kids
like like eating gushers and
yeah i think it's a little rude it
wasn't broken
yeah
yeah i ate a lot of just peanut butter
sandwiches on a roll a lot of cheese
sandwiches a lot of pretzels it's famous
i used to just drink slim fast as a
drink
[Laughter]
you know yeah anything box of cereal go
through the whole thing at tasty cakes
when they came back from the store
yeah it was a nice leave a [ __ ] chips
ahoy cookie sure who ate all of these i
just bought them i yeah i never was not
eating the cookies there never was like
a put away but um the uh were you a
sugar cereal household yeah would you
parents got whatever you wanted yeah
really yeah huh because there's a thing
with that i don't know which one's right
i know kids that had tons of sugar
cereal well if you don't [ __ ] with it
like if you're bringing me kashi home i
would have been [ __ ] pissed man i
remember going to my boyflips house and
they had kashi we were like in seventh
grade i like some of the adult cereals
though shredded wheat was like the most
disgusting i should be freezing the
[ __ ] new york times the frosted
listen the frosted wheats i would say
were the least sugary ones we had really
holy that would be every once in a while
i got into kicks but that was just i got
into it they're all right
i liked i liked pop pops
come on that's straight sugar cereal you
had a good run of apple jacks yeah they
had a solid run for a little bit they
did i was hopping all right or was that
honeycomb was darosa gonna sue us for
stealing his
hot
bro
they were on taste buds trash and grape
nuts which i strongly disagree i
actually there's not much i love them i
don't know what that is grape never even
had it it's almost like dried oatmeal
it's geriatric cereal yeah yeah but dude
i tell you talking about grapes
if you soak that in milk you let it sit
for an extra couple of minutes the
bottom gets mushy and you have a little
crunch on the top with a little bit of
sugar it ain't bad people are afraid of
that mush if you're afraid of the mush i
love the moisture that mush is so good i
love life cereal i'll let that sit for
like 20 minutes and then now
did you guys um i used to hang out at
the pool a lot the public pool yeah
which you had in your neighborhood for
some reason was that like it was well
maybe it was private actually it was
like those different townships had a
different one you remember the name of
it yeah glenside pool okay no glenside
is a um the township pool yes like i
think we did have a swim that's a swim
club yeah where to pay they have teams
and stuff like that that's actually nice
i've been there it's a classy operation
they got a decent snack bar yeah
yeah my niece and nephews used to belong
to it they were on the swim team yeah
for a little while yeah okay so
swim club summers were all right the day
they're staying there every day the days
seem to be like a thousand hours each oh
we were so excited you would be swimming
for like what seemed like 14 hours like
what time is it though it's not even
lunch you're like what the [ __ ] i don't
even know if my parents had sunblock
like we were i was burned to chris there
was multiple times where i would get
huge blisters
blisters in like [ __ ] august and my
mom didn't make me put on sunscreen and
i woke up in the middle of night look i
got hit with a blow torch it was [ __ ]
terrible i remember being down the shore
and i went in i was like can i have some
sunblock and she's like no i want to
peel it off later
yeah they used to oh they love peeling
that's a hot move real creepy it was i
know we're all like peel it off
hopefully you're not uncircumcised
she wasn't peeling anything else where
are your parents now are your parents in
the philly area still right they are the
same house they grew up in you grew up
in new york
and all that ebay money i got all that
drop off ebay
they're in one more but they're going to
move to jersey to be closer my brother
moved to cherry hill okay we're moving
to jersey yeah we're becoming jersey
people that's what happens in philly you
do your and then at some point you go to
jersey because it's cheaper or whatever
whatever
um it doesn't matter for you really you
come home it's like whatever go to
jersey go to philly i want my ponytail
to look cute for a second on the podcast
what are you thinking about buying a
house you're going to buy one out there
i don't know what i want to do because i
do i am like
i don't care how this sounds but i am
deciding how much money i want to make
okay i had spiritually sure all right so
i don't know if i want like where do i
want to live do i want to try to go
really rich and go live in malibu or
something it's going to be la though
it's going to be the west coast i'd like
to have houses okay different places
would you ever move back here and get a
place in jersey or something like that
be close to the fam
not to live permanently but yeah okay as
an investment property yeah as an
investment property maybe you'll buy
this house for your parents
put them in there
maybe i bought vacation this summer
you paid for the whole family i only
paid i paid the
like the deposit which was like 75
percent and i was like you guys can pay
the rest just because my business
manager was like what are you doing
relax yeah where where is the vacation
um poconos
i thought you're gonna say like honolulu
or something yeah i thought you're going
to say santorini i'm glad you think that
though
so you picked up tolls you get it
yeah
what is it is it a lodge
we got like this big giant house yeah
the whole family the whole thing those
houses can't get expensive i was
perusing the other day is it on a lake
it is
yeah there's a like i think a lake near
there but it we're just gonna hang out
we just might it's fun we pl we hang out
with the kids we all hang out all day
yeah yeah and they go to bed everyone
smokes weed my brother has like thc
drops now your parents smoke weed yeah
well now we take the drops everyone gets
high it's hilarious man the whole family
huh just everyone laughs just faced out
yeah chilling
it's funny though it's just everyone's
laughing you guys play games like
[ __ ] pictionary or you know
this one but
it's trashy heads up heads-ups all right
but you can record them if you're always
a good time if you're on vacation and
you put you play heads up with your mom
or your aunt those kooky brothers don't
know what
yeah but here's the thing my dad at
about to turn 81 is so
good at heads up like he's so quick so i
like doing games where we remind my dad
his brain isn't going away oh yeah i
think he's like nervous about that i'm
like you're [ __ ] smarter than all of
us we're all so dumb compared to my dad
he's so much smarter than us they really
dumbed down through the generations what
do you do with the kids on stuff like
that
on a vacation like that you have
anything planned we're like every once
in a while i mean we went to the beach
we went to long beach island which was
not i've never been there before
it's very different it was
pretty nice it's very natural it's like
pretty [ __ ] long beach is like proper
rich people like it was we went one
summer and we were we stuck out like
sore [ __ ] thumbs it was so weird i
ran into everyone kept throwing your
towels
i ran into my ex-boyfriend's friend best
friend and his
wife the guy in jail no no no like a
boyfriend i had like
i don't know six years ago or something
okay okay and i did go say hi but it was
so
awkward he was
yeah i know he's a civilian okay and
then that but it was i was already doing
comedy and stuff when i was dating him
okay and then but running into them i
like recognized them and then i was i
went over like oh my god and then it was
just painful i mean it was like
because i don't i'm not
talking to this guy i didn't want to
bring him up because not that we had a
bad breakup but it's just like out of
boundaries of course so i just there was
and she goes okay sunglasses on she goes
okay i know i just give her like a luna
you can have this
um but i go
i just i'm like like because i i can't
get out of a conversation she just goes
okay well nice to see you and i went oh
okay
there's not going to leave it's always
weird because you want to close it but
if someone else closes the door and you
you feel like a real jerk like have you
seen my career growing like maybe you're
excited
patreon what's going on
so what are you doing though what am i
doing now
see the purse
just like oh well i keep like did you
talk to ben have you seen ben
that's where when you bump into people
that you don't see that often or from
like a time in your life when you're
like
you only have some sort of weird
connection through somebody in college
you're like hey you see [ __ ] steve a
lot and they're like steve's dead yeah
oh [ __ ] you know mine's worse because i
was like a drunk girl so i'll see people
from college like remember when you were
on roller skates and you would like come
knock on my door and try to suck my dick
i'm like first of all no i don't
remember that at all i don't know that
that even happened i needed an a
and it's like people you're like i could
not imagine you i was trying to suck you
knocked on my door and tried to suck my
dick
these are the rumors these are the
rumors this is slander libel and i won't
stand for it i will tell you one thing i
don't remember it i can't i did own
roller skates i did have roller skates i
got a good will
but i can't imagine uh do you donate the
goodwill now
no no
no what do you do with the old stuff
that's so bad it's actually so bad
i put it in a bag and i go it just never
makes it there it gets shoved somewhere
there's so many bags of clothes going to
goodwill i'm going to take i want to
donate i'm always like then i'm like
maybe i could like maybe girls for that
watch my podcast want them i don't know
they're not like bad clothes i just
don't i don't like how i want to get new
clothes no of course
the new york does a pretty good thing a
lot of the buildings or whatever will
have my old building used to have it in
the building yeah we just go downstairs
oh that's awesome
and they donate i'm pretty sure the
super was sifting through it and taking
the good [ __ ] first yeah i saw him
wearing my blazer one time but you know
how's my underwear jose you do you
um i want to donate more because i you
just don't i just end up throwing it out
it's also i don't know all cheap like h
m [ __ ] so it's like
who needs a [ __ ] h m t-shirt that's
been washed 400 times i know i'm just
like i've sweat a lot it's like there's
yellow pit stains do you use buffalo
exchange at all you go drop off clothes
there i'm uncomfortable with the whole
situation
i don't want to be around other people's
old clothes i don't i respect that i
don't like i've never when my mom had
the ebay drama story i think i'm
traumatized but it's like i don't want
other people's things even though i
understand like that it's cool and it's
like we're over producing things and
making too much waste and stuff but i'm
like
can you guys do that and then i'll just
buy the new things you said the place
the place that you're at now you see the
closets are stocked with a bunch of [ __ ]
is it chaos i'm sure it looks nice when
you walk in but if i peek around it
doesn't it doesn't no no no no no we
need a maid or something this is crazy
it's i'm not i i am a messy person i
have add i've always been this way and i
always am one of those people i'm just
getting to the age where i'm like i
don't think i'm going to change
you know how you always i'm also
accepted i'm going this is who i am
shit's going to be [ __ ] up who cooks
at the house when you guys are home and
you have a night off you make dinner
he's cooking he cooks he does all of it
everything he's yes we have a deal that
he that he came up with i didn't come up
with it sounds abusive if i came up with
it he does 90 and i do 10. okay
can you cook anything
i mean i could i could
you throw out some scrambled eggs or
something i can cook every once in a
while he gets breakfast on his birthday
when i got him pork roll from the grove
and i went and got him like kaiser bones
bones buns
i got him kaiser
i got him
no it's tell's birthday because i
haven't sucked his dick i'm like oh my
god it's still your birthday
i didn't give him his birthday blow job
yet
anyway this has been about i'm making up
for the christmas all right i'm like oh
merry christmas you're gonna have the
[ __ ] i'll get
do
your
choice
oh my god my niece's birthday
yeah sexual favors on flag day okay
that's my niece's birthday is it yeah
what are you doing for the kids you
throwing down on the kids pretty hard i
got my girl like how many are there how
many nieces and nephews i just have four
i just have two boys on my one brother
and two girls in the other
brother
they're two brothers it's starting this
is my first year really like because i
mean there were times where i was like i
had my parents like get my [ __ ]
ticket and [ __ ] i had to do that up
until about six months oh i know it's
like just changing yeah yeah it's tough
it's great
it's not tough good feeling [ __ ] fun
um so what are you throwing on them
birthday presents i got like okay so
for instance and hold on do you have any
competition in the family of being
the high roller i mean timmy my older
brother is like the type of guy that's
like if you're like my if my other
brother's like oh we gotta get a new
fridge he'll be like i'll buy you the
fridge and people it's too much it's
weird for you to buy
but when it comes to the kids there's
nobody else
they're like we'd rather what when it
comes to the kids there's nobody else
nobody like timmy has kids of his own
yeah he's not going overboard with they
do good i think i think you know maybe
they just they just try to get them
something they're gonna like it's not
nobody's really like no but you are you
doing the power wheels are you doing
this i've done it yet i haven't done it
yet you know it's a good i do
i do for the birthdays and for christmas
christmas specifically because the so
many kids that get so many presents from
these kids
um cash is all right at a certain age
but i give them something that they'll
even if it's like 20 bucks that they'll
play with that night yeah like oh yeah
yeah sweet i don't and i'm like i don't
care if it makes scope i don't care if
it makes it home you ripped it open you
had 20 good minutes with it take this
break kev wins i'll see you later i got
um i got my niece for her 10th birthday
i got her matching lockets that have
like our pictures in it okay okay i've
been waiting to get her that for a long
time because she wasn't old enough
appreciate it i'd recommend nintendo
switches or ipads yes well that's
awesome
my older brother does all that stuff you
know what i mean that's also tough same
with my brother it's like the kids have
everything and i'm like yeah they're
gonna you know whatever so it's like
give them something
like i wanted to get her a sick drone or
something but i'm like i think she
already has a drone like i just have to
i'm gonna have to start really
she worked for the cia what the [ __ ]
i already got a predator
she's got her own aircraft carrier she's
got a couple of tanks what are you gonna
do double digits now she's killing it
all right let's do two more then we
gotta wrap this up this has been a hater
she's a good time man she comes in like
a tornado she's a good time she's like a
breath of fresh air keep she keeps
love her
[Laughter]
maybe 47 times uh
this one's from andro do you smell your
own pee after eating asparagus no you
don't i do i mean i i can't help it i'm
not sniffing at my own pee yeah two
seconds after i eat it it's all over the
place i don't smell pee i'll leave it
i'll
i'll let yellow mellow so i'm not really
nothing why that why not just why not
just flush it down
it's asserting dominance your
boyfriend's okay with that can he get
away with the same thing he's part of
the ninety percent can he pee in that
flush sure i don't care what if he pees
on the seat
are you getting upset at that if you go
in i wouldn't get upset sad i wouldn't
get upset i'd just be like what's going
on how are you not mm-hmm are we pooping
and showering in the same thing would
that happen
if you were sharon he was taking a poop
that's cool
and vice versa open door policy oh
that's love right there i like that i
love him yeah oh yeah i love it what's
the farting situation oh back and forth
all over him really
he pays me only on his birthday all
right do the face throw you do that
sometimes no no need it it's already
vibrating on his body
uh do you or anyone in your family use
the side door this is sorry for this
from reginald uh use the side door
and not the main door to enter the house
you've got to be psyched are you like
girl you know you coming through the
garage it through the back not the
proper front door you'll probably come
through the growing huh you guys coming
into the chimney growing up
yeah we would do back doors that yeah
yeah we have a real backdoor vibe you
also i remember if i remember correctly
you were that wasn't a sexual innuendo
by any means but you were also loose dog
people yes you had like you had like
neighborhood dogs packs and dogs yeah
which was how do i ever no no our dog
was the only one there was no other dogs
it was only the letter it was everyone
was so pissed at us it was crazy they
were very upset with us like we were the
neighbors everyone hated
were the doors unlocked always always
unlocked no keys never locked ones
if they were locked we would just punch
like my brothers and i like i remember
cutting a screen and like breaking into
the house because it felt so it's always
getting through the base there was
always some way to get in i was so
entitled to getting in and out of my
house no matter what like if something
was locked i was like
we would all just punch
a window oh yeah my personality is
[ __ ] kidding me oh that's crazy
um all right this one's from josh how
often are you eating over the sink
oh trash sink yeah
let's just say how often am i sitting if
i'm eating at a restaurant i'm sitting
if i'm anywhere else you're kind of
mobile
at the house are you guys eating if say
he does make dinner you got the night
off the tv okay
i i'm watching jeopardy i'm watching you
do have a kitchen table i would assume
or something like that or like a dining
room table we have a we have a like an
island like a bar yeah yeah but we i
decided so we live in a loft so it's
like the there's a loft that he has his
um office his editing office up there
okay then there's a second bedroom
that's got that's for my solo podcast
that i haven't started back yet but it's
coming back so it's kind of like all my
things are in there
and um
and then we have our bedroom which is
just a [ __ ] mess the way it should be
though
really day-to-day most people unless
you're you know i have never met most
people's places are pretty [ __ ] up
i've maybe made a bed like like five
times i like not having the bed made i
like having it all never never never
yeah it feels like your space it's our
little cozy space i just am done trying
to like because i feel like i was
putting so much pressure on myself to
like be this like better person and i
was like i just want to accept myself
the way i am this is how i am and then
hopefully i make enough money in the
future to get someone to do that what
they're going to do well there's also
the acceptance of like buy your way out
of it being a better human don't beat
yourself up you're like this is who i am
why just like learn like get around it
like don't you feel like that would like
okay so when i think of like doing a
special i've always been like oh god i
have to like put all my jokes into the
specific order and i got to do and i'm
like i'm that's not how i perform that's
not your that's not good
myself a different thing
it's like when people go to like the
tonight show it's like that's not
everyone looks crazy yeah it's like
that's not you know that doesn't fit
every mold of comedian but it's like
just going so hard yourself and then
seeing if everything else will just
accommodate you like seeing if it will
yeah
you're in the toilet and keep a messy
bed and eat in front of the [ __ ] tv i
know i feel like the thing is going to
upset people
no i don't think so i don't have any
[ __ ] floaters on purpose okay i can't do
it because my my my urine is too pungent
i don't know what that means it's like
i love how he's trying to play it off
like he's eating a lot of vegetables
he's like it's just all the asparagus
it's all the ecto quality of the drink
it's strong it's strong it's like deer
rut i'm telling you why but i like to
yeah i start my dominance over the
bathroom
the queen of the castle i'm the queen of
this throne piss on the front door keep
the other keep the other birds away get
the other podcasters away so you're
eating a meal
on the couch in front of the tv at the
coffee table yeah follow you're not
married i'm not i'm not uh me and my
girl been together about six years oh
okay yeah what's she up to what's she
done uh she works uh she has a good job
do they like going on the road with you
guys or no no nobody goes on the road
wow they're not like a little bit like
oh look all these people love you no no
they don't care they're totally cool
yeah yeah no no not like jealous i love
when todd comes i make him do my merch
and stuff is awesome
and people know about him because i talk
about him
we had a little we when we did a just
like an ayg french ayg and friend show
in the city at this place uh sesh common
in lower east side and we got there
there was a line and yeah my girl came
my lady and we got out of the cab and
there was like you know like 80 people
like standing in the line they were all
like oh like
she i didn't know she was not
ready for she hadn't seen that she
hadn't seen it yeah that's crazy and
they all know her because she's like a
character on the show they're like
and she was like she like grabbed my
[ __ ] what the [ __ ] is this i'm like oh
yeah this is it's so cool it's so fun
yeah she was at the show in philly so
she thought she she saw it yeah she saw
it yeah it's a good time it's good to
show them you know that this is not a
bozo no more this was [ __ ] worth it
all right show our families then yes oh
my god it's amazing when i put down that
deposit i didn't pay the full thing
but it felt the second time you said
that in the polka dots
there can be no i know that there's no
way i'm on my way i'm on my way
you felt good doing that great it's a
good feeling as i assume you were always
kind of i don't you know the bozo of the
family yeah same with us we were always
the two bozos and now it's nice to you
know just be recognized for being here
it's also like i've just made a career
off being an idiot so once i started
getting tv credits though it started to
slowly like even though the money wasn't
there they were like
once i got on like chelsea lately they
were like okay we won't like kick you
out of dinner
like you don't have to sit in the van
with the dogs anymore yeah there's an
extended part of my family that looked
at me like i was a rack of yard tools
until i did that thing on manna-fest
look at that
i remember when that hit the first time
they looked me in the eye i know i
forget you're an actor you were in my
weren't you on my pilot forever ago yes
i was it was you and metzger and monroe
yeah i've watched that you were in that
yeah i was in that you watched that
yeah because you're like i passed on it
but
they're like who looks like him that we
could get in the role that's scarier and
taller
disturbed wow
kurt i get metzger a lot yeah yeah
you're a shortcut uh no i think i saw
through monroe or whatever yeah like the
beginning of the teaser of the one the
screener
yeah caught the screener what'd you
think it was cool i remember yeah it was
it was cool
also andy it was [ __ ] 10 years ago i
don't have the cliff notes on it
what'd you think what'd you think of
that third scene you think i was in it
what the [ __ ]
where you going locked up you're locked
up oh you got it
so what'd you think i didn't
i like the two guys that girl was a
little over there was a girl in it
i just thought it was three dudes ladies
and gentlemen miss annie letterman buddy
we love you trash tuesdays anything else
you want the folks out there to know
um i used to call the jerky boys line a
lot you guys remember that remember the
jerky boys
i've been plugging dates before no of
course when does this come out
when i was younger
a week or so all right i'll be in austin
texas uh july 29th it's gonna be very
fun i'm going to be hanging around after
that i'll be at the vulcan for two shows
i love the vulcan i'm not going to be
like i'll just stay and party with the
boys awesome tony all that stuff
[Music]
i'll tell tony what's up i'll tell rogie
you said hi shout out joe
and
i am going to
be in a bunch of places go to annie
letterman dot com shows awesome i have
my sunglasses you got them somewhere i
do floating around somewhere sunglasses
got her own sunglasses i got them right
here they're cool
they look good on you i think boys feel
like homeless pimp
i just want to let you know all you
garbage people out there you too can get
rich
sign up sign up for my newsletter i'll
be telling you how my name is harry v
i'm gonna do that i'm gonna [ __ ] do
that i'm gonna blow up on tick-tock as
harry v you're gonna have some kind of
master class i would assume you'll give
them the first couple of minutes and
then [ __ ] well i do have a criticism
i do hypnosis and here's the thing you
want to give people free of charge wait
hold on but here's the thing are we just
hypnotized right now you do hypnosis
like you give it out or you get hypnosis
both i'm learning i'm training i got a
class tomorrow my last class another
test on sunday i gotta fly in get in it
at 7 00 a.m
in la go home shower
it's a zoom class but shower just to be
cute and then i got to take my test my
final test a hypnosis test yes
[ __ ] strain hypnosis
hypnotist i mean hypnosis i said it
wrong
no but i don't know what i'm going to do
with it but you know you can't grow
people don't take things seriously if
they get them for free you got to charge
people sure i love it i love it buddy we
love you thank you so much for coming
and sit with us kippy what do you got
for him guys the next leg of the middle
class famous tour tickets are on sale
right now it's going to be seattle
portland uh kansas city st louis
springfield jersey that show's about to
sell out right bank baby get them uh
nashville indy tickets link is in the
description check it the [ __ ] out oh
wait [ __ ] i have another thing go ahead
hit it i have my a spotify show coming
out on the 11th yeah there you go on
july 11th awesome don't bore me with
annie letterman and it's going to be
interactive it's just audio it's great
um i probably am not supposed to say the
competing thing but it's an audio thing
where you can pull people up and talk
and stuff
and so i'll just be it'll be fan
interaction [ __ ] with everyone
fantastic i love my fans i love your
fans i'm proud of you guys
rise up with us people come with us and
there's one in the end you're gonna have
to die and there's one way to do that
follow me on tick tock tick tock
tick tock buy my emerge buy my emerge
we'll see you next week
keep me in first buy my merch see you
guys